we had illegal aliens attempting to
to traverse the perimeter fence at one
of these local schools in the southern
side of the city
um and that school ribbon chevy
elementary school had to go on lockdown
temporarily just to make sure that the
students were safe
so i asked i asked congress i asked
those politicians that are out there
advocating for different nations right
now stating
you know the calm and the care that we
need to provide them what about our what
about my elementary school students
imagine how the trauma that they're
experiencing having to be on lockdown
for
illegal immigrants coming in and trying
to get into their fence line
that's ridiculous he is a democratic
mayor the mayor of del rio texas and
he's calling for congress
to put americans first by taking action
on the border crisis
as he reveals that a surge of migrants
trying to enter his town
forced a school to go into lockdown 13
illegals were detained trying to get
over the fence of that school here to
react is fox news contributor laura
trump good morning laura
good morning ainsley thanks for having
me thanks for coming on so here you have
this democratic mayor
and he is siding with ted cruz here he
says i've gone to congress
he was blasting aoc but he is praising
ted cruz for admitting that this is a
crisis what do you say
well good for him by the way for coming
out and talking about this and he also
held to account
some democrats in congress specifically
aoc and saying that what she has said
is not helping the situation but gosh
ainsley can you imagine
being a parent of one of these children
and knowing that the school had to go on
lockdown
because you had illegal immigrants
trespassing on the property i mean this
is
horrifying stuff this shouldn't happen
in america but this is the result
of open border policy this is the result
of joe biden and kamala harris
inviting all of these people into
america this is what happens
when you spend tax payer money to pay
for
people who have broken our laws by
coming here illegally to stay in america
you give them free health care
you invite all these people and you
allow children of illegal immigrants to
go to
in-person school and tell american kids
they still
can't go in person they have to say
virtual this
is insanity it is really scary but
look we have to get a hold on this again
i praise that democrat mayor
for coming out and talking about this
this is not a partisan issue
this is an american issue and where
is kamala harris where is joe biden
kamala harris
has been tasked with fixing this problem
for i mean gosh how many days and
counting now months now
and she still hasn't gone to the
southern border and by the way i'd like
to remind joe biden you might have
forgotten
you're the president of the united
states you might have told her
this is her job it ultimately falls in
your lap at any moment you could go down
to texas you could go down to the
southern border of america
and get this problem under control but i
think the bottom line ainslie
they don't want to do it it is crazy and
people are really getting fed up
it really is crazy i mean aoc and 34
democrats are objecting to these border
agents
deporting aggravated felons they don't
even want to report the gang members
let's talk about what you touched on a
little bit with the masks with our
children the cdc is recommending that
kids wear masks
at school i know you have little ones at
home how do you feel about those
well i do not put masks on my children i
never have
i never will i think when you look at
the science and gosh weren't we all
supposed to follow the science from the
beginning what
is not what we were all told the science
has told us very clearly
that children thank god do not react to
covid in the same way that adults do
that they are not the super spreaders
people thought they might be a year ago
if you have
teachers either getting vaccinated or
not worried about
covid then why are we masking up our
children this is
pure insanity here i got to tell you i
know a lot of parents
who are saying if you mandate that my
child wears a mask or you mandate
that i get the vaccine for my my you
know five six year old
i'm not sending my kid to school and i
can't say that i blame these people
as parents we know what's best for them
this is not
up to the schools to tell us the school
board the cdc
this is up to the parents in america
it's really good i can't believe that
they're saying that we should do this
brian interviewed a young lady who was
playing basketball and she
passed out and she ended up in an
ambulance and had to go to the hospital
she had
they're forcing those kids i believe
it's in oregon
to wear masks while they're playing
sports
unbelievable i can tell you i was an
athlete growing up it's hard enough
to to run down a basketball court full
court and play that game
if you're massed up it is even worse
this is crazy stuff that's going on i
can't even believe it
i know has anyone said anything to you
if you go out in public without the kids
wearing masks
well it's funny because i i talked about
this this weekend i take my kids to a
playground
and oftentimes they are the only kids
without masks
outdoors ainsley at a playground nobody
said anything
they just give you looks but that's okay
we'll take that laura thanks so much for
coming on
you got it good to see you